the araucaria tree is extraordinary in
many ways
and not just for its enormous size or
its sharp and scale like leaves
it grows very slowly and can live for up
to a thousand years
a prehistoric species in fact
but the araucaria is much more
about it is a sacred tree for us
it is our mother and father because it
provides us puente with our food and
sustenance
maria romero is the name
taken by the native mapuche who live by
the andes mountains
before harvesting the araucadia's fruit
called the pinon
she asks for its permission and gives it
thanks
for centuries until this day the pewens
have bartered or sold their binonis for
survival
they're extremely nutritious in fact
we're told they also help increase
fertility
can i try one they're like chestnuts
[Music]
on this day we're invited to eat them
for dessert
maria romero is a wentuchefe or healer
and explains that the bignones are more
than food
i can then fundamental the aracaria the
water the earth the air
that we need to live don't need us it is
us who need them
that is the mapuche vision the mapuche
believe that man's abusive nature is
causing climate change
drought and illnesses like cancer and
the pandemic that we're witnessing
the indigenous people of chile realized
long ago that if they over exploited
their natural resources
they would die of hunger which is what
happened to the native americans in the
united states when the white man
exterminated the buffalo these days the
concept of living
in harmony with nature is actually
becoming mainstream
so much so that many chileans who've
long regarded the mapuche with contempt
for believing that people should take
from nature only what one needs
are beginning to understand the need for
all to do the same
lucian newman al jazeera launching chile